[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur ce plateau
celui de face aux territoires avec nos
partenaires ouest-france ouest france.fr
nice-matin nicematin.com
franceantilles.fr et lamontagne.fr ainsi
que 20minutes.fr qui sont les
partenaires donc 2 face aux territoires
ce matin mon invité c'est le directeur
général de l'ifop c'est frédéric dabi
bonjour frédéric dabi bonjour avec vous
on va essayer de regarder quel est
l'état d'esprit des français puis l'état
aussi des sondages des intentions de
vote pour ces élections législatives qui
arrive traille dhabi vous avez écrit la
fracture aux éditions les arènes avec
stewart show c'est le livre que l'on
voit actuellement sur l'écran on en
reparlera évidemment dans l'émission
également une question qui me vient à
l'esprit tout de suite en vous regardant
six mois avant les élections
présidentielles 60% des français rejeté
emmanuel macron
le deuxième tour a eu il ya quelques
jours dimanche dernier soixante pour
cent des français ont voté pour lui
qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça montre
recherche cir et d'une faute plus que la
popularité n'est pas le vote vous avez
raison et ben macron a été un président
impopulaire c'est à dire il a une
majorité de permettre et c'est
compréhensible par exemple par un groupe
à tonnerre de la france mais est ce
qu'est ce que nous aimons mais on nous
regarde pas un peu curieusement mais
vous savez la popularité dans une
période de crise c'est extrêmement
compliqué mais je retourne votre
remarque est complètement juste six mois
avant son élection dans tous les
indicateurs et fort peu nous avons trois
indicateurs de popularité 1 avec paris
match est le plus ancien la 5ème
république avec du journal du dimanche
il était à 40 2 43% de personnes
satisfaites c'était nettement plus que
tous ses prédécesseurs sauf les
présidents qui était en quoi en
cohabitation il avait il a un socle de
popularité minoritaire mais un bloc
important alors par le passé votre
marque était tout à fait pertinente à
l'époque aussi où il y avait une
bipolarisation gauche droite un
président avec seulement 43% de
satisfaits risque est que par
automaticité des français se tourne vers
l'opposition
qu'est ce qui s'est passé depuis 2010
est il n'y a plus une opposition mais
des oppositions éparpillés et il a tiré
parti de ceux de cette fragmentation du
champ politique 43% rc bien élu emmanuel
kron il a été bien élu alors je trouve
que je vous donne la jouer ou parier
plus à titre personnel katyn
professionnels c'est un débat qui me
gêne terriblement nos institutions la
vème république la présidentielle c'est
50% plus une voix prenons un exemple
historique en 1974 giscard d'estaing et
élus de seulement 500 mille six cent
mille voix il se prépare à un septennat
très difficile georges marchais et
françois mitterrand ne l'a ne retiennent
pas leurs coûts pour autant jamais ni
georges marchais ni françois mitterrand
n'attaque giscard d'estaing sur le fait
d'un président mal élu et du de peu ce
n'est pas ça le combat politique on à ce
poison dans le débat public de remettre
en cause la légitimité des élus on l'a
vu en 2012 avec françois hollande a il a
manqué quelques jours à nicolas sarkozy
pour gagner on l'a vu en 2017 avec ewan
mc rond et on l'a même vu aux élections
municipales on à déligitimer la victoire
de mr ait eue avec une forte abstention
alors on va voir si ces élections
législatives sont le troisième tour de
cette élection présidentielle avec
frédéric dabi directeur général de
l'ifop qui est notre invité ce matin
d'en face aux territoires dans un
instant françois-xavier le franc le
rédacteur en chef de ouest france est
avec nous
[Musique]
bonjour françois xavier le franc on
voudrait te rédacteur en chef du plus
grand quotidien francophone du monde
ouest france et on va parler des jeunes
et du vote exactement bonjour frédéric
dabi les jeunes vous les avez beaucoup
étudié et votre conclusion ça tient en
deux mots la fracture c'est le titre de
votre livre dont on va beaucoup parler
dans cette émission car lease
passionnant je tiens à dire c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on souhaitait vous
avoir ce matin cette fracture elle
s'exprime aussi dans le vote c'est à
dire que les v2 les jeunes votent peu et
vote sans doute moins que les autres
générations il avait été 9 sur 10 des 18
24 ans à ne pas voter aux dernières
régionales et départementales au monde
la présidentielle que ça confirme est-ce
que la présidentielle confirme cette
tendance là les moins j'ai envie de dire
pire mais 42% des français dans un
sondage ifop fiducial pour le jour du
vote ne sont pas allés voter de primo
votants ceux qui votaient pour la
première fois à une présidentielle et ce
n'est pas une fatalité de l'abstention
des jeunes il ya eu des élections
présidentielles où les jeunes ces plumes
aux votants ont voté autant voire même
en pourcentage plus que l'ensemble des
français mais des élections spécifiques
l'élection de 80 des élections de
rupture 95 2007 la dernière élection
toute la france a voté massivement là
c'est vrai que 42 % ça conclut un cycle
électoral où le vote est de moins en
moins naturel pour les jeunes car de
moins en moins il croit que le vote que
l'ailé que l'élection peut changer les
choses se changer leur vie ça veut dire
qu'on va décider de l'avenir du pays
sans eux c'est entre c'est ce qui est en
train de se mettre en place ce qui
paraît quand même
hallucinant la fracture est là
malheureusement on a depuis maintenant
2007 c'est une date assez intéressante à
partir de cette date tout c'était une
élection incroyable de rupture de
renouvellement des candidats nouveau les
français je mets de côté les régionales
de 2015 post attentats ont voté système
est systématiquement moins à l'élection
que à l'élection de référence précédente
c'est vrai que à peine 58 % des jeunes
qui votent ce n'était du gc du jamais vu
à la 5è pluie avez vous le sentiment que
les les responsables politiques ont
conscience de ça parce que ils sont très
peu à en parler alors quand on regarde
moi même ce qu'est notre démocratie
quand on regarde quand même le degré de
tension qu'il ya dans le pays et quand
on regarde cette fracture qui ne cesse
de s'agrandir on se dit qu'on est quand
même mal parti pour l'avenir c'est vrai
que ça peut être inquiétant alors je
nuancerais sur un point les jeunes
sondés politisés ou de sens comme ou
dans le sens où comme le dit très bien
françois xavier ils votent de moins en
moins aux élections en 87 % d'abstention
aux élections régionales 42 % aux
élections
l'élection présidentielle avec une 1 une
raison d'abstention qui est très
inquiétante c'est une raisons de logique
que j'appelle de vanité du vote voter
ces vins voter cet inutile et dans les
manifestations frédéric dabi on adore
dans la rue j'allais vomir cyril ils
sont peut-être dépolitiser ils ne sont
pas désengagé dans une enquête nouvelle
vague que j'ai construit pour ce livre
une enquête qui a été fait pour la
première fois en 1957 pour françoise
giroud dans l'express on a trois quarts
des jeunes qui se disent engagées
notamment sur la question du climat donc
en clair la politique les passionne
parce que c'est ça le climat est un des
sujets f de mobiliser longuement sais
pas c'est pas le seul mais il estime que
le vote n'est pas le bon levier
finalement pour agir ça reste un bon
levier mais ceux de moins en moins le
levier unique ils cohabitent avec
d'autres leviers alors selon vous qu'est
ce qu'il faudrait faire pour que les
jeunes soient beaucoup plus
dans le système politique active et
aujourd'hui puisque c'est celui qu'on a
comment faire pour les ramener parce
qu'on a besoin d'eux on a besoin de leur
énergie qu'on a besoin de leur
contestation on a besoin de leurs votes
on a besoin qu'il soit entendu parce que
ça ne peut pas continuer comme ça
longtemps on se dit quand même que c'est
strictement inacceptable en démocratie
techniquement on peut faire comme en
vrai en fait à leurs questions je pense
pas que ce soit une question de
technique bien sûr on a des seins on a
testé des moyens techniques le vote par
internet le vote par correspondance mais
mon certains parlent du vote à 16 ans
que les jeunes eux-mêmes rejettent
majoritairement c'est moi une question
technique d'une question de sens
retrouver le sens la signification du
voc 2007 steve à yacine en tant que ça
2012 des jeunes à des voté après c'est
quoi c'est l'instruction civique qui
mûrit école c'est peut-être ça mais
c'est l'idée leur faire comprendre que
voter voter pour des élus resterait ce
contrat de confiance entre la délégation
du vote et le résultat a un sens et ce
avec la crise que nous traversons qui ne
touchent pas que la jeunesse ya quand
même une abstention plus forte que par
le passé on a quand même eu 13 28 %
d'abstention au second tour de la
présidentielle même s'ils avaient des
raisons politiques et qui au vote
mélenchon etc c'est cette logique ce
relativisme 7 à quoi bonne isme sont de
vote et la crise que nous connaissons
est une crise dure résultats avec bon
sens il avait le france voudrait qu'on
regarde juste les tableaux sur
l'abstention will a fourni il faut que
vous vous interrogiez frédéric dabi là
dessus c'est déterminant de l'abstention
vous appelez ça il a déterminant reste à
expliquer je ne suis pas de voter le
dimanche 2 capable on les voit là
pendant que vous parlez oui alors ce qui
est très intéressant c'est que on
retrouve cette logique qui était qui
était très forte au premier tour de
vanité du vote voter ne changera pas ma
vie votre faute et ne sera pas là s'il
est la situation du pays las pour le
second tour il ya une raison spécifique
aussi c'était la fiche macro le pen qui
a rebuté beaucoup de français qu'il est
renvoyé dos à dos on se souvient de
billets de l'abstention record de 69 le
blanc bonnet et bonnet blanc entre
georges pompidou et alain bauer qu'en
est-il dans l'union européenne est ce
que est ce que c'est une spécificité
française ou est-ce qu ailleurs dans
l'union européenne dans les autres pays
on retrouve ce taux d'abstention chez
les jeunes
malheureusement l'on retrouve un peu
partout parce que chez les jeunes il ya
une belle enquête européenne qui a été
fait il ya pas très longtemps par la
fondapol de dominique reynié on à ces
jeunes qui se disent faire avancer les
choses c'est mon à titre collectif qu'à
titre individuel qui mieux que moi peut
faire avancer la cause du climat par mes
gestes individuels par ma participation
à des mouvements que ce vote où on voit
une certaine
procrastination que les jeunes notamment
sur le climat ne supporte plus c'est à
dire ils nous disent il ya des codes 21
22 23 24 et chaussures a pas eu d'écho
anxiété qui structurent beaucoup le vote
déjà cette enquête auprès je crois de
dix mille jeunes c'est un panel
extrêmement exactement elle disait aussi
que ces générations sont extrêmement
angoissés oui c'était même le mot
angoisse donc voilà revenez souvent est
ce que c'est ça qui explique à votre
avis c'est vrai que la jeunesse en
france a connu quand même des fractures
des chocs le choc terrorisme le choc
climatique le choc du coc vide dans le
bouquin gens pas énormément et là le
choc de la guerre qui les inquiète et en
nommant ses sept nombreuses peut-être
qu'il ait pas qu'il est paralysé leur
fait croire de moins en moins à la
capacité pour du vote à changer les
choses
françois-xavier lefranc rédacteur en
chef de ouest-france le journal aussi
130 cartes de presse a refusé c'était
une volonté de lui même et de sa
rédaction de publier avant les élections
présidentielles les intentions de vote
s'étaient pas très bon pour vous les
sondeurs vous avez pris comment ce que
ouest france a fait alors déjà l'ifop a
la chance depuis une trentaine d'années
de travailler avec ouest france sur des
sujets de société sur des sondages ne
veulent te référence et c'est un choix
que je respecte mais je trouve qu'il ya
une pédagogie à faire des intentions de
vote et malheureusement ces faits dans
la presse n'est pas assez de manière
approfondie je précise que ce que nous
avons mis en cause ce n'est pas le
travail des sondeurs c'est plutôt le
travail des médias utilisation et cette
utilisation en boucle en permanence des
intentions de vote qui ont une influence
sur le vote parce que s'il ya eu un vote
utile en faveur de macron de le pen et
de mélenchon c'est bien parce que les
intentions de vote répété en boucle
disait qu'elle était le vote utile et
quel était le vote entre parenthèses
inutile bien juste c'est quand même
embêtant dans une démocratie qu'on en
arrive à penser qu'un vote puisse être
inutile on va coûter française avait le
franc donc chaunu qui est un dessinateur
bien sûr très connu et collaborateurs de
ouest-france cas une question à poser à
frédéric dabi on l'écouté le regarde
bonjour quelle histoire premier
président de la cinquième république à
être réélu sans période de cohabitation
emmanuel macron dès le soir de sa
victoire et partis s'isoler à versailles
tout un symbole pour éclairer sa
lanterne
bon il faut dire que les enjeux sont de
taille le choix du premier ministre
hommes ou femmes les élections
législatives la guerre en ukraine la
liste est longue dès la proclamation des
résultats les oppositions veulent
imposer au président de la république
une cohabitation avec un jean luc
mélenchon qui rêve d'avoir la peau de la
vème république
à défaut d'avoir la tête emmanuel macron
alors la question je posais l'ordre
médical pour soigner les maux de notre
république ne faut-il pas institué dès
maintenant une dose de proportionnelle
pour que bien l'assemblée nationale soit
plus représentative du nouveau paysage
de la vie politique française
a alors oui qu'est ce qu'il faudrait
faire oui la proportionnelle peut être
une escale de levier important pour
résoudre cette fracturation le problème
de l'abstention relais aux législatives
c'est que les français ne voient plus
l'autonomie de ce scrutin indexer sa
présidentielle donc la proportionnelle
ça permettrait de 2,2 notamment aux
jeunes de dak de constater que leur vote
est vraiment pris en compte oui bien sûr
quand on voit que marine le pen en 2010
f et 34% et à sept députés si le même
schéma se met en place il y aura un vrai
problème démocratique est la une d'ouest
france françois xavier le franc alors
chef alors beaucoup d'employeurs
recherche
des salariés c'est le cas notamment dans
la restauration
70000 saisonniers saisonniers sont
attendus impatiemment dans la
restauration voilà donc on a fait une
enquête une enquête sur ce sujet et on
évoque également
l'escaladé militaire aux frontières de
l'europe parce que tout cela tout ce que
l'on se dit ça se fait dans un contexte
quand même extrêmement dangereux il faut
le rappeler françois-xavier lefranc
rédacteur en chef de ouest france est
partenaire co producteur de cette
émission merci dans un instant denis
carot de nice matin sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis car en merci d'être avec
nous on joue devant ce matin genf dhabi
de directeur général de l'ifop qui
s'occupe aussi du pôle opinion à
l'intérieur de cette maison sleaford
pour les téléspectateurs et bien c'est
le grand sondeur français et nous avons
le plus ancien nous allons démarrer tout
de suite avec un petit passage du côté
des antilles de fort-de-france où cyril
bouty est notre partenaire qui est le
directeur éditorial de france antilles à
une question à vous poser on écoute
bonjour frédéric dabi en guadeloupe en
martinique en guyane les électeurs ont
voté à plus de 60% voire 70% en
guadeloupe pour la candidate marine le
pen au second tour de la présidentielle
un vote de contestation massif qui
imposera désormais au président de la
république réélu de devoirs entre
guillemets parler différemment à ces
territoires comment peut-il envisager de
le faire et comment les élus de ces
territoires peuvent-ils aussi envisager
de parler différemment à leurs électeurs
c'est vrai qu'il ya une spécificité
incroyable en 2017 mais macro à 75% dans
ses étés dans ces territoires il se fait
écraser par marine le pen on a très bien
vu que le vote de colère de jean luc
mélenchon est passé très naturellement à
la différence de la métropole vers
marine le pen ça ne sera pas anodin pour
ce quinquennat dans ces territoires
denis carot un pays face à ses divisions
frédéric dabi on a le sentiment à la
lumière de du résultat de cette élection
que on a deux france qui cohabitent une
france contestataires plutôt populaire
qui a voté marine le pen au second tour
et qui avaient voté aussi pour
pour jean luc mélenchon une france plus
privilégier une france de deux cadres de
retraités pour qu'ils emmanuel macron
était un choix rassurant est-ce que
c'est caricatural de considérer que le
pays est coupé en deux il effectivement
coupée en deux sur ce premier tour voire
en trois camps 2 j'allais dire il ya eu
au premier tour trois blocs mais ces
règles sur ce second tossée second tour
qui intéresse rarement on a eu une telle
fracturation électorale par le passé on
avait des ouvriers qui votait à droite
on avait des cadres supérieurs ou des
personnes très fortunées on l'a vu en 81
88 qui votait à gauche là c'est vrai que
sur le diplôme sur le niveau de vie sur
la distance au centre ville il ya un
vrai clivage alors contrairement à cette
caricature sur les socios c'est pas tous
les électorats mais c'est vrai que les
65 ans et plus ont voté à trois quarts
pour emmanuel macron les ouvriers à
trois quarts pour marine le pen de ce
point de vue là on a des choix
extrêmement déterminé et des deux
électorats antagonistes superposables
sauf sur un point le salariat ça sera
peut-être la bataille de ce quinquennat
séduire lézarder les français marine le
pen progresse de 8 points par rapport à
2010 est on a vu le score de jean luc
mélenchon est ce que il ya de la part
d'une partie des français la volonté de
renverser la table baron là on l'a vu
est-ce que élire marine le pen s'est
renversé la table oui c'est de moins en
moins vu comme un saut dans l'inconnu
mais ça reste compliqué pour beaucoup de
français c'est ce qui explique cette
dimension non pas de plafond de verre
c'est un terme inapproprié mais de deux
murs qui l'empêchent de basculer vers la
45 à 47 % le battage et le vote d'une
france diplômés et le vote d'une france
comme vous le dites qui va bien on a vu
les différences très nette entre le vote
des villes des grandes villes
favorable très largement à emmanuel
macron et le vote des campagnes 57 % des
communes de moins de 1000 habitants ont
voté pour marine le pen qu'est ce que ça
veut dire oublions même des sondages dit
marine le pen arrive en tête dans
dix-huit mille communes dans 23
départements c'est que dans ces
territoires alors faut pas globaliser
les campagnes ya une ruralité heureuse
et ruralité qui a connu un véritable
dynamisme moscovite notamment en termes
d'attractivité mais dans beaucoup de
campagnes il ya ce sentiment d'abandon
ce sentiment de relégation et le signe
pour ces français c'est le démantèlement
l'absence des services publics lorsque
ces les services publics c'est les
déserts médicaux
exactement n'oublions pas la main sic
est plus là pour nos téléspectateurs la
santé en france est devenue la première
préoccupation des français depuis
septembre 2019 avant la crise qu'ovide
déjà y avait l'inquiétude sur l'hôpital
public et il ya cette question ces accès
aux soins et dure de six mois pour un
scanner il est long c'est l'accès aux
soins la renonciation aux soins et sa
touche également les métropoles trouvons
retrouvez des rendez vous chez d&g des
spécialistes au jour du jour au
lendemain c'est terminé et encore plus
fortement dans ces communes rurales on
se sont relégués et le fait que les
métropoles grossistes qu'elle est aussi
une puissance administrative aujourd'hui
plus forte est-ce que ça accentue ce
phénomène s'accentue même si locaux
vides arbres équilibrer les choses en a
on a observé un phénomène de des
métropolisation les français ont quitté
quand même beaucoup de métropole à
démographiquement il ya eu un petit et
par goût ou l'arrière ou et vers les
villes moyennes vers les villes où là le
choix d'un pavillon est plus facile que
dans une métropole il ya peut-être un
rééquilibrage qui a aussi profité aux
communes rurales mais à des communes
rurales et une france rurale une
diagonale du vide qui reste encore très
fragilisée est-ce qu'ils votent le pen
est ce qu emmanuel macron peut d'une
certaine manière
rééquilibrer entre les grandes villes et
les les codes les plus petites communes
vous parliez de ce rééquilibrage pendant
la crise sanitaire est ce qu est ce qu
il a les moyens d'aller plus loin alors
c'est vrai que ça a été quelque chose
qui a été réussi dans du premier
quinquennat il s'est mis à dos beaucoup
d'associations d'élus est d'accord
intermédiaire les corps intermédiaires
il ya le programme coeur de vie qui a
donné des premiers bons résultats
pour autant c'est quelque chose qui ne
se voit pas les français attendent des
résultats concrets ce type de
rééquilibrage se voit difficilement
pourquoi ça se voit pas parce que des
français de le vif a concrètement c'est
des portions du territoire ça va
beaucoup mieux du coup la fibre du côté
de l'accès à internet il ya de nouveau
des lignes
france ils se sont beaucoup beaucoup
réduit on le voit même nous dans nos
enquêtes un autre dans notre capacité à
toucher en dans des enquêtes en ligne
des ddt des territoires intérêt qu'on
n'est plus emmanuel macron a expliqué
dimanche qu'il n'était plus le candidat
d'un camp mais le président de tous ce
qu'est ce qu'il doit faire aujourd'hui
pour réparer pour réconcilier les
français très vite oui vous avez raison
d'une par ce type de phrase est quand
même une antienne traditionnelle après
une réélection c'est un défi pour lui
n'oublions pas que les traits d'image
qui lui allait le moins quitté nîmes et
les télés - associé pendant la campagne
présidentielle et pendant tout son
mandat
c'est la connaissance de la vie des
français et sa capacité à rassembler il
a un vrai atout là dessus et quand on
voit les en parler des critiques sur la
légitimité de son élection de ce point
de vue là le climat n'est pas un climat
propice à ce type de rassemblement la
une de nice matin denis carot vous êtes
le directeur de la rédaction du groupe
n'est ce pas là une de nice-matin leur
nouvelle vie de prof tous ses salariés
du privé qui quittent leur emploi pour
se lancer dans l'enseignement ils sont
de plus en plus nombreux et puis il ya
une petite une du mag sur cyril lignac
aussi un petit peu d'art de vivre envoyé
cyril lignac rica s'est installé à saint
tropez et voilà
vous y allez y allez on va y rester
merci denis carot directeur rédactions
du groupe nice matin c'est à dire vers
matin et monaco matin bien sûr merci
denis carot co producteur de cette
émission dans un instant armelle le goff
de 20 minutes sur ce plateau
[Musique]
voilà où mène le goff bonjour merci
d'être avec nous et armelle le goff la
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
je rappelle c'est un partenariat entre
ouest france et la voix du nord merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes également
partenaire de cette émission dans un
instant on en vient à vous mais tout de
suite on part retrouver françois chez
taille qui est notre partenaire du
groupe centre france la montagne
il représente le journal le pays et
journal un des journaux de ce groupe
depuis roanne il a une question à poser
à frédéric dabi on écoute vous a dit
bonjour on a tendance à considérer que
les jeunes votent plus à gauche que
leurs aînés qu'ils sont si plus
concernés par les questions et
écologique on remarque toutefois que
permis lectorat rassemblement national
les moins de 35 ans sont assez
nombreuses et on sait également que
l'abstention est très forte parmi la
jeunesse lors des dernières élections
régionales 87 % des 18-24 ans ne s'était
pas rendu aux urnes alors ma question
est simple
existe-t-il vraiment un vote des jeunes
pour le dire différemment existe-t-il un
vote par classe d'âge concernant les
jeux nes je vais être rapide pour le
rassemblement national et pour toutes
les forces il n'y a pas une jeunesse il
ya plusieurs jeunesse marie le pen a
fait un score plutôt faible chez les
primo votants dont on parlait tout à
l'heure des moins de 24 ans par contre
chez les 25 30 les 25-34 la génération
de l'insertion celle qui peinent à
entrer sur le marché du travail qui a du
mal à qom qui disons 3 la terre de
traditions voilà traverser la rue la
marine le pen est arrivé à quasi égalité
avec jean luc mélenchon il ya un vote le
pen jeunes et ce qui est très
intéressant par rapport au vote et
reines du passé c'est que c'est un vote
d'adhésion par un vote de contestation
c'est un peu normal non c'est un pays
multiples mais toutes les heures
jeunesse non plusieurs jeunesse mais par
le passé cyril y avait un vote ce jeune
spécifiques les jeunes voter pour des
candidats qui n'accède pas au second
tour isa et beauté marché en 80 besançon
doubs et mamère en 2002 là les jeunes
votre quand même globalement que
l'ensemble des français même s'il ya eu
1 sur vote très spectaculaire pour le
candidat mélenchon avec deux niveaux il
parlait du climat puisque l'hymne et que
janot et surtout c'était un vote utile
pour éviter marine le panneau au second
tour armen le kof oui on va essayer de
se projeter sur la composition politique
qui va se jouer du coup après cette
élection présidentielle d'après vous à
quoi faut-il s'attendre pour les
élections législatives à venir alors
c'est simple depuis l'inversion du
calendrier électoral et législatif placé
après la présidentielle celle ci ont
perdu toute leur autonomie législative
ne font que confirmer la présidentielle
on l'a vu en 2002 en 2007 en 2012 en
2007 il ya une sorte d'effet de souffle
et surtout un différentiel de
mobilisation les électeurs des belles
macron confirment leurs votes de premier
tour ceux des oppositions des fêtes ont
du mal à se mobiliser là où il ya un
petit changement un grand changement
c'est que la campagne police nathi va
commencer dès le soir du premier tour
pour jean luc mélenchon dès dimanche
pour marine le pen et il ya une volonté
de mobiliser ces électorats peut être
mécontente de la fiche du second tour et
de la réélection de mme anna cros pour
lui imposer une cohabitation les
français y croient même si l'histoire
électorale montrent que ça relève point
0 son premier ministre du voeu pieux oui
c'est un du marketing politique fort
alors ça n'a absolument aucun sens mais
dupont politique du marketing politique
c'est très bien joué est ce que vous
pensez qu'une mesure a annoncé pendant
la campagne sur les retraites le départ
à 65 ans peut mobiliser les oppositions
pour ces législatives
donc oui pourquoi c'est un sujet aussi
épidermique - parce que pour les
majorité de français la retraite c'est
un acquis social quand on fait une
enquête en 2021 pour les 40 ans de
l'élection de françois mitterrand pour
la fondation jean jaurès la première
chose qui reste des mandats mitterrand
ce n'est pas la peine de mort comme en
2011 pour une enquête faite pour le jdd
sous les trente ans c'est la retraite à
60 ans c'est d'un c'est un acquis social
et les français ont le sentiment
s'inscrivent dans une logique de der des
ders à chaque réforme des retraites on
leur dit allez c'est la dernière fois
pour sauver le soldat et baroque et la
réforme revient donc quand macron parle
de gaulois réfractaires sur les acquis
sociaux de ce point de vue là oui mais
ça peut être comme vous dites une un
élément de mobilisation rappelez-vous en
2007 comme la tva sociale à effet mal à
sarkozy entre les deux tours des
législatives en gros 50 députés de plus
de gauche c'est qu'en prenant le maire
dit pardon sûr
radio du service public que l on va
passer avec le 49-3 alors il a fait un
bien fou tu vois non il n'a pas dit
qu'il a besoin d'un petit film il a pas
dit que l'esa qui a été retenue c'est ça
eh ben c'est une gaffe ou pas c'est une
ça peut être vu comme une gaffe dans la
mesure où ça réactive une méthode
autoritaire brutale des réformes
précédentes eurent échangé sur un sujet
extrêmement brûlant épidermique vous
évoquez la prothèse une cohabitation
pourquoi c'est un un mode de
gouvernement que les français
affectionnent finalement ils l'ont aimée
parce que c'est un mode de cohabitation
mode de gouvernement je dirais prémat
cronje on prend le meilleur de la gauche
qui est au gouvernement le meilleur de
la droite qui préside 97 2002 pour
autant que c'est de la fausse union
nationale exactement c'est une puisque
on peut pas faire de coalition continue
de notre mode de scrutin c'est quelque
chose dans l'imaginaire des français qui
peut séduire maintenant je pense qu'on
est très très loin d'une cohabitation je
ne vois pas comment l'effet de souffle
présidentielle la mobilisation des quand
même deux mois après sept semaines après
effectivement c'est une c'est un élément
de nuance pour autant ce qui est très
difficile c'est la mobilisation des
français en deux en 2017 on était passé
du premier tour de la présidentielle
77 % de participation au premier tour
des législatives à 49 pour cent vingt
huit points de moins donc lhi facebook
ce l'effet de souffle ça marche toujours
à priori d'après ça a toujours marché
mais ne disons pas ne prenons pas que
les modèles du passé les le contexte est
spécifique c'est le deuxième mandat
teman macron souvient encore 88 françois
mitterrand avait eu une majorité
relative d'un cheveu il peut peut-être y
avoir plus une campagne quand vous dites
syrie plus long que prévu puisque
l'élection a lieu dans cette semaine
peut-être avec en plus un élément un
carburant électorale la réforme des
retraites qui pourrait stimuler les
oppositions c'est aussi le souci on est
plus sur une opposition mais des
oppositions et par commence
exactement l'offre de gauche vous parler
des législatives qui interviennent après
l'élection présidentielle
à pau le 18 mars emmanuel macron a parlé
de de me remettre en place de la
proportionnelle éventuellement et de
repasser au septennat est-ce que vous
pensez que finalement ce cetc
modification du rythme électoral pourra
redonner du souffle à la démocratie
j'invite dit on parlait déjà de la
proportionnelle en 2017 pour le mandat
ça ne s'est pas fait je pense que c'est
des choses qui peuvent être intéressants
mais les français sont ce placement sûr
c'est logique institutionnelle que 7 des
logiques de résultats et qui les
concernent directement en tout cas la
proportionnelle pourrait vraiment avoir
un effet on en parlait juste avant avec
denis carot de limiter ses critiques sur
une assemblée qui ne ressemble pas non
pas sociologiquement français mais alors
vote emmanuel macron a déclaré vouloir
nommer un premier ministre attaché à la
question sociale à la question
écologique à la question productive qui
fredonne avec davy voilà et une fiche 2
pas une forme adéquation avec les
attentes des français clairement oui il
ya une urgence climatique environnantes
elle même si pendant la campagne on en a
peu parlé parce que cette campagne a été
écrasé par le pouvoir d'achat la vie
chère l'inflation la relégation et etc
sincèrement je me livrerai pas au jeu du
pronostic à zut alors j'ai alors une
femme une femme pensait que ce serait
par une enquête ifop jdd de ce matin
montrent que trois quarts des français
souhaitent qu'une femme soit nommé
talent qui entend pourra nous laisse
aborder des questions vous n'êtes pas
sur lci juste pas sur terre on est entre
nous mais n'oublions pas qu'en 2017 des
dizaines de noms avaient été données
avaient été livrés en pâture souffre
christine lagarde si celui jour edouard
philippe oui si mme lagarde elisabeth
board barbara pompili ont pas en parle
même de noter at-elle dit kosciusko
morizet qu'il reviendrait sa retraite
américaines je n'en ai absolument aucune
idée c'est pas mon rôle en tout cas
quand même les français quand malgré
tout sont moins sur une logique de
casting que sur une logique de résultats
ils peuvent aussi apprécier la
philosophie d'un gouvernement il avait
beaucoup
apprécié la logique de 2017 qui était on
met une sportive au sport un médecin à
santé
ils ont un peu déchanté mais c'était une
philosophie qui plaisait oui la société
civile qui est aussi le pouvoir le champ
du pouvoir on voit aussi que des
ambitions se déclare pour 2027 la
prochaine élection présidentielle est-ce
que c'est trop tôt est ce que du coup en
plus avec des partis qui sont quand même
qu'ils ont montré qu'ils ne fédérer plus
beaucoup lors de cette élection ce qui a
pas un enjeu quand même parce que ceux
projetés aujourd'hui sur 2027
n'intéresse absolument pas les français
c'est vrai que depuis 20 heures 2
dimanche on a basculé sur la prima kron
ce n'est pas le calendrier des français
qu'est ce qui se passe entre edouard
philippe l'ancien premier ministre et le
président de la république salaires se
passait mal y compris les négociations
concernant la wii sur aurizon on a vu
des tiraillements quant aux horizons a
voulu intégrer agir en tout cas edouard
philippe gardent une popularité est
insolente quand on a interrogé emmanuel
macron nombre on peut s'en passer
je ne n'ai pas la réponse à votre
question on se souvient du précédent
pour pidoux de gaulle en 68 69 il vaut
mieux peut-être avoir les doigts
philippe au gouvernement qu'on électron
libre à l'extérieur gouvernement
s'annonce le premier si rapidement
khabar savez on a eu alain juppé qui a
été celui d'orsay jean mallot russe jean
marc ayrault qui a été lancé ce ne sera
pas pour n'importe quel poste la une de
20minutes lundi d'ailleurs c'était le
lendemain du deuxième tour très belle
une arme elle voilà nous sommes en
vacances à 20 minutes sur le print pas
sur les supports digitaux qu'ils
continuent à fonctionner 7 jours sur 7
24 24 mais là c'est la une du coup de
lundi et ça marche encore visiblement
pour emmanuel merci armelle le goff
directrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
partenaires cette émission dans un
instant et bien moi m 4,6 nous rejoint
de tv5 monde
[Musique]
voilà bonjour m cas si vous êtes
toujours lors de cette chaîne très
connus vous animez le 64 minutes sur tv5
monde notamment et nous allons parler
avec vous des questions internationales
avec pour commencer évidemment l'ukraine
et oui bien sûr bonjour frédéric dabi
bonjour alors le poids de la guerre en
ukraine sur la vie politique française
mais d'abord quand même le vote des
français de l'étranger qui nous
regardent et qui rate face aux
territoires ils ont plébiscité emmanuel
macron 86% un peu plus contre 13% un peu
plus pour marine le pen s'était 92% et
vous le dire c'était il ya cinq ans en
2017 voilà c'est quand même rapport de
force extrêmement proche où sa mère l'a
n'y a pas de fracture comment expliquez
vous cette tendance ben c'est un vote
légitimiste c1 c'est un vote aussi qui
met en met en relief l'appréciation des
réformes économiques des manuels macron
c'est ce vote de ce que j'avais appelé à
la salle la sainte alliance de
sympathisants elle est réelle et rennes
qui tout au long du quinquennat ont
soutenu l'action économique des macros
et dans la sociologie des français de
l'étranger on retrouve une sociologie
proche de 7 ans et une petite différence
marine le pen est arrivé en tête en
russie bien cinq ans est arrivé en tête
en syrie ça veut dire que les français
qui vote qui sont établis hors de france
y tiennent compte ils s'inscrivent dans
un contexte politique international et
local tout à fait eric zemmour est
arrivé en tête je crois en israël au
premier au premier tour pas au deuxième
au second tour ça a été très net pour
mails macron je crois oui à une prise en
compte du contexte alors je n'ai pas le
corps électoral en tête mais ça et ce
n'est pas anodin en tout cas on voit
très bien c'est souvent avec légitimiste
les français de l'étranger ils avaient
voté
fortement pour le président sortant
c'est pas forcément des gens ultra aisée
dans le coin c'est pas toujours
regardants qu'il faut pas avoir et aulas
je l'espère le même type de eur2
hypnotique dans cette voie hier aux
députés
sachant soit supprimée m'hamed
extrêmement réclamer c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup
à chaque élection c'est plus 2012 ou
2017 de turquie à ces français c'est 11
de ses conscription il ya vraiment
beaucoup de mangas beaucoup plus de
circonscription par le passé ça prend en
compte la part des deux français de d2
de l'étranger qui croît régulièrement et
effectivement c'est souvent une valse
cerveau d'un port mission
d'intention de sa rôle important parce
que quand on est député français de
l'étranger en afrique de l'ouest où des
violences pour la région maghreb voit
avec la question du sahel avec les
relations notamment sur la question
migratoire ça a son importance vous avez
d'autant plus à raison que si un
mouvement de fond que je vois dans nos
enquêtes d'opinion depuis une dizaine
d'années c'est l'intérêt croissant des
français pour les questions
internationales
l'époque où s'était cantonnée à des
français les dires il se jouer dans une
élection bien oui alors ça n'était pas
là quand même vu l'ukraine alors aux
métaux lourds qui a jeûné qui avait
anesthésiée la campagne parce que de
plus en plus les français ont le
sentiment que ce qui peut se passer au
bout du monde au grade l'europe a des
conséquences concrètes sur leurs risques
vous avez parlé du choc de la guerre en
ukraine c'est vrai que l'invasion russe
elle a impacté la campagne électorale
mais sur l'issue du scrutin mais masque
emmanuel macron a bénéficié de sa
stature internationale notamment
d'ailleurs marine le pen dans le débat
de l'entre-deux-tours à commencer par
plus tôt enfin je veux dire du bien de
sa campagne afin de semer de sa
politique étrangère tout à fait il ya
toujours un effet drapeau pour le
président de la pluie qu'il ya une crise
internationale il ya toujours un crédit
sur ses adversaires dans une campagne
électorale je rappelle qu'en 2010 qu'en
2012 quand on travaillait sur le match
de crédibilité hollande sarkozy le
président le candidat hollande l'emporté
très largement sauf sur les dimensions
internationales et c'est vrai que émane
macron a bénéficié d'une mais pour cette
man combien est-ce que ça est-ce que ça
fait basculer le scrutin séché la séance
quand dans les derniers jours de la
campagne on est passé à une valérie
pécresse qui séduisait 40% de
l'électorat fillon avec lui pour cent
pour finir à 20 % on a eu un électorat
de droite âgé qui était dans la logique
on change pas de capitaine au milieu de
la centaine pour saluer fortement
médical et eric zemmour à ce que les
sondeurs se sont trompés ce qu'il était
surcoté ou est-ce que effectivement les
passes et dylan du sur vladimir poutine
lui ont fait du tort à la dernière
enquête de l'ifop le met à huit et demi
il fait 7 je pense qu'il ya vraiment eu
pour lui un avant et un après silencieux
en ce moment ag pas la réponse très
sincèrement mais hier il a il a dit hier
que le transall il présente pas de
candidats fouilles
encontre menées contre elle même pour je
tiendrai jeu à matérialiser une
candidature quelque part je vais
répondre à votre question précédente 80
ans qu'est ce qui explique son
effondrement je pense que il était à 16
ses ennemis avant la guerre du cren il
perd très fortement du terrain il a
perdu son atout majeur qui était cassée
en moi eric zemmour est celui qui dit
des vérités qui annonce des choses et là
sur le crâne il s'est trompé et a été en
dissonance avec tout l'électorat sur son
refus d'accueillir des réfugiés lundi le
mall quasi esclaves vladimir poutine
avait un candidat à cette élection ou
une candidate je ne le pense pas je ne
le pense pas alors il ya eu 7 7 passes
d'armes pendant le débat d'entre deux
tours avec les meilleurs conques a
clairement pris le point de ce point de
vue là d'ailleurs marine le pen qui
restait sur une logique d'être très
calme sur la forme pour oublier l est
elle avait deux adversaires à un marine
le pen lors du débat la marine le pen de
2010 est très très agité et très peu
experte et emmanuel macron à mon avis
sacrifier une bad a une comment dire une
réponse agressive pour garder ce calme
et cette maîtrise vous disiez tout à
l'heure que les français étaient
intéressés par la politique étrangère on
parlait notamment de la jeunesse est ce
que vous retrouvez cette fracture dans
la jeunesse française sur les questions
internationales notamment sur ce conflit
russo ukrainien alors très clairement de
la jeunesse française l'inquiétude sur
ce conflit est plus fort que la moyenne
des français l'agresseur est très
clairement désigné c'est vladimir
poutine et cette jeunesse française est
inquiète parce que là la guerre en
europe à une haine elle ne connaît pas
et cette affaire ukrainienne constituera
le choc supplémentaire après tout les
chocs qu'elle a encaissé depuis des
années le choc terroriste le choc
climatique et la différence de la
jeunesse passée ont connu des crises des
chocs mais il y avait toujours une
croyance que le politique pouvait
résoudre ces convertis et même sur
l'ukraine il ya un autre que moi je
voulais savoir est-ce que ce troisième
tour de la présidentielle qu'on annonce
sera un troisième tour difficile
conflictuelle est ce que vous voyez
naître comme en fin de campagne
présidentielle c'est agressivité
réciproque ou paula là on a vu hier qu'
un accord se dessine entre les insoumis
et le parti swiss est très intéressant
c'est là qu'on disait que parti
socialiste allait être totalement
inspiré par les insoumis est-ce que ça
va être paisible où est-ce que ça va il
ya l'enjeu il ya deux choses le
différentes les tensions l'agressivité
le porte voix parfois un peu mal faisant
des réseaux des réseaux sociaux
n'arrange pas les choses maintenant sur
lequel moscou maintenant la gauche la
gauche molle et la gauche qui étaient
incapables de s'unir à l'élection
présidentielle semble dans de meilleures
dispositions pour les élections
législatives mais comme je le disais
sont en jeu à elle la gauche aux arènes
à toutes les oppositions des mails
macron c'est la mobilisation de la
lecture en mini c'est la chose la plus
importante la fiche premier ministre de
jean luc mélenchon là je sors un petit
peu du capot et c'est risqué ou pas
comme chou annoncé que c'est un bon coup
marketing mais ça n'a absolument aucun
sens additionnel est ce que les français
aiment les joutes à l'assemblée
nationale tip
ce qui se passe toutes les semaines à
londres quand le premier ministre vient
devant le parlement se faire rabrouer
est ce que les français sont prêts à
avoir ce type de démocratie à
l'assemblée nationale je pense que oui
même si malheureusement dans notre
démocratie dans notre régime
présidentiel si peu parlementaire la
scène parlementaire est très peu visible
des français y a qu'à voir les audiences
et de questions d'actualité des
questions elle n'est pas négligeable
mais c'est un public extrêmement type
est extrêmement spécifique est-ce qu'on
peut aller vers ça avec ces assemblées
qui vont être composé de personnages
quand même deux personnalités faut
changer de musique les women loris et 10
et plus
oui en tout cas dans sa peau est
peut-être intéressant pour le spectacle
mais les français ne se situe pas dans
ce type de logique et puis faut pas
oublier le poids de la monarchie de la
figure et même de la magie
présidentielle reste assez peu de temps
est ce qu'il ya un effacement du premier
ministre en france est ce que jean
castex a été le directeur de cabinet
emmanuel macron est-ce que celui qui va
être nommé sera moins fort alors que les
français réclament un exécutif plus fort
en tout cas le quinquennat d'un côté
l'hyperprésidence de l'autre nicolas
sarkozy
inventer face à price et soeurs ont été
aussi d hyperprésident d'humour prime
aux collaborateurs
voilà il y a un problème d'incarnation
plutôt de positionnement du premier set
les français restent très attachés à ce
couple exécutif et jean castex oui
peut-être plus visible a été plutôt bien
perçue par des françaises notamment sur
sa gestion du quotidien de la crise qu
vide est-ce que c'est un poste le
premier ministre en france qui reste un
poste intéressant tu nous parles d'enfer
de matignon savent ya beaucoup de il ya
beaucoup de prétendants il faut savoir
imaginer un premier ministre heureux il
y en a eu quand même notamment edward
fils qui est parti de matignon avec un
véritable état de grâce en tout cas les
français je pense pas qu'ils seraient
favorables à la suppression du poste et
un basculement total faire un régime
présidentiel où le président il reste
devant l'assemblée à la manière des
premiers sans glace et on a 30 secondes
un directeur général de l'ifop heureux
est ce que les français les sondages ça
marche alors je suis heureux à titre
personnel à titre professionnel des
sondages sur vous de
l'est
moi je suis frappé de voir que deux
choses les français répondent aux
questions qu'on leur pose et les
français acceptent de participer aux
enquêtes d'opinion ils sont
complètement libres d'accepter ou de
refuser frédéric dabi directeur gardien
de l'ifop qui a été notre indiqué
aujourd'hui d'en face aux territoires
merci moi mais ces syriens si je
remercie vanessa chala rédactrice en
chef pascal quentin qui coordonne la
production de cette émission nicolas
renard qui dirige la production de cette
chaîne et véronique rawson sac qui est
rosenwaks qui est nôtre réalisatrice
merci à tous on se retrouve jeudi
prochain pour un nouveau face aux
territoires au revoir
[Musique]